voici le premier bateau amphibie routier
100% homologué pour venir rouler sur la
route ça veut dire que vous voulez
prendre votre bateau partir sur la route
et vous balader qui dit bateau homologué
pour la route dit forcément ceinture de
sécurité l'idée c'est vous prenez votre
bateau sur la route vous pouvez être 4
personnes et vous allez aller à 16 km/h
maximum une fois que vous allez avancer
vous allez rentrer dans l'eau et ensuite
vous pouvez être à 6 personnes maximum
36 nœuds à bord de votre tringle et vous
pilotez tout directement ici vous avez
un e-cockpit sur lequel vous allez
retrouver toutes vos commandes vous
allez voir votre vitesse de déplacement
vous venez ici sur le côté vous allez
pouvoir mettre hop vos veilleuses vos
feux ici les essuie-glaces directement
ensuite on le sauve vous avez aussi
plein de petits boutons neutre parking
démarrer reculé parce que forcément
c'est une voiture votre clignotant d'un
côté et de l'autre bien évidemment vous
le démarrer ici votre klaxon vos warning
on a un écran de 12 pouces vous avez
forcément un grand menu sur lequel vous
allez pouvoir retrouver vos différents
outils de bord bref c'est un bateau
voiture un bateau routier un bateau
routier surtout une fois de plus
homologué vous pouvez l'acheter et aller
vous balader à côté de chez vous si vous
voulez